et vous pouvez dire vous pouvez
commencer à faire ça comment
od que j'ai commencé à sortir habillé
comme ça oui je suis tombé sur des gens
qui m'a agressé dans la rue en me
demandant d'effectuer une domination sur
eux j'envoie les membres spontanément ce
genre de choses
des hommes qui s'agenouille devant vous
et qui vous demande de venir
votre esclave alors ça a défini le
personnage que je cherchais un petit peu
et que j'ai défini et qui feront fait
mon personnage naturel championne une
vingtaine il y en a
certainement plus mais celles qui font
ça et pour leur plaisir et avec une
certaine recherche esthétique sont rares
comme moi rigoureusement unia congolaise
marie-laure c'est interdit par la police
vous faites par la loi et certaines
pratiques sont interdites l'armé blanche
ou tout ce qui a un caractère de
mutilation mai
les pratiques elle-même étant sur le
consentement du sujet qui se présentent
à vous n'ont absolument rien à
l'interdît et mouvements qu'ils aient
majeur il ya pas de moment qui les
nageurs il n'a pas en difficulté sur les
la police fait d'ailleurs une très
grande confiance aux dominatrice dans la
mesure où elles n'ont jamais d'ennui
oui il ya un côté qui est presque du
professeur david qui permettent d'agir
avec une grande sécurité et d'obtenir la
confiance des sujets quels que soient
dans le dos les deux sujets qu'on vient
de voir qui a été réalisé par marca
riches ont une séance un petit peu
inhabituel dans la mesure où il y avait
des caméras et on imagine que ça dérange
un peu la pratique habituelle mais quels
sont les services que vous fait subir à
valentin par exemple au cours d'une
séance normale
il ya sévi ces douceurs il ya toujours
une interne entre la tendresse c'est le
hélas la recherche d'une
d'une douleur celle sujet qui lui permet
de dominer pour nous alors les services
c'est plus classique sont évidemment la
flagellation
c'est un type d'humiliation consiste à
obéir à des caprices qui peuvent être
complètement bizarre
il ya évidemment des supplices par le
feu je crois qu'il ya un petit exemple
un aveu brûler ses poils c'est ça et
nous sommes allés dans certains cas
jusqu'à des saignées ou d
ces disques qui sortent du domaine vie
convenable même voulu accrocher des
choses au bout de oui tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est pur tout ce qui est
sensations liées à la peau c'est à dire
le fait de gratter avec les ongles de
gratter avec des surfaces rugueuses way
ou des multitudes des pin
c'est un excitant érotique colossal et
on s'en sert énormément justement pour
faire à la fois très mal et a développé
une très grande et des situations
identiques et en particulier les tous
les points du torse du ventre de la
terre cuite sont extrêmement sensibles
les zones érogènes avec jeux les plus
sensibles à ce genre de pratiques mais
elle te fait vraiment mal tu as vraiment
mal mais vous savez il y a deux types de
douleur mais il ya une douleur qui est
provoqué par la fréquence des coûts nous
mais non par la force
virons par la rapidité des coûts et il
ya une douleur qui est provoqué par la
forme du coup tient la même profondeur
et on peut jouir de multiples douleurs
il est évident que les douleurs les plus
dures à supporter sont les douleurs
provoquées par la fréquence découvre
voulons et que la qualité d'une
maîtresse c'est aussi de savoir donner
des coups donc de savoir respecter son
esclave et de lui donner des coups à la
fréquence que l'esclave de man
j'ai déjà essayé avec d'autres
maîtresses ma maîtresse m'offre beaucoup
d'autres femmes à long terme mais je
serai très facilement valentin parce que
il
il est désiré parce que notre loi parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de stoïcisme coups de
courage devant les choses mais il est
très sélectif n'accepte pas d'être
dominé par n'importe qui et quel effet
sexuelle ça te fait alors parce que la
vente à du band pas vraiment parce qu'il
ya les caméras et tout ça mais
d'habitude ça te fait bander ça l'effet
sexuelle est certes un certain et
définitif
est-ce que tu arrives à jouir sans
masturbation sans pénétration lorsque tu
subis des des services comme justice
échouent mais davantage avec des
humiliations du type les chéquiers de ma
détresse plutôt qu'avec les coûts qui
sont davantage du domaine de l'intellect
mais au fondeur est ce que tu es jacques
hull sens qu'est ce qui t'arrive
d'éjaculer comme ça sans
on s'en branle et sans ne servent en
laissant pénétrer c'est arrivé mais il
n'en est pas toujours conscients alors
d'accord je prendrai aucune claude été
témoin de situations de ce genre en
présentation publique c'était comme une
humiliation et en même temps une offre
oui il ya eu une accumulation très
impressionnante conti n'a pas eu
conscience éclairée la pire chose que
vous ayez eu à lui faire un domaine de
la saignée ou domaine de la brute de la
ceni a été très impressionnante parce
qu'il n'était pas prévue du fonds elles
ont fait ça avec deux amis c'était très
impressionnant je crois que tout le
monde a un souvenir marquant de cette
séance
sinon il ya eu aussi une autre séance
qui était très dur puisqu'il est il a
failli s'évanouir avec des marques sur
les fesses ils ont extrêmement forte
avec un mythe objets que devrait
apporter l'eau qui est très très
dangereux
il ya une troisième séance où nous
sommes allés très loin puisque une de
mes amies a marqué en broderie avec
du fils de chirurgiens sont initiale sur
le sein droit de valentin et que
quelques heures
les instants après quand je lui prêtais
une autre amie ouais il s'est épanoui a
été ou la saignée si particulière au
creux des bras au creux des bras en
creux des coudes et le sang coulait le
long des le long des bras jusque dans
deux verres de cristal qu'on avait
disposé pour ça et on a répandu son sang
sur lui même et on lui a fait finir une
des deux coups il a eu d'ailleurs
beaucoup de peine à le faire on avait
réussit et le sens lons on entend tout
le long de la c'est très impressionnant
parce qu'il s'y attendait pas il sait
absolument sfr avec je crois beaucoup de
plaisir et de
d'abandon est ce qu'en général c'est
plutôt des hommes ou des femmes qui
viennent nous voir pour ce genre de
grande majorité des hommes parce qu'ils
n'osent pas le demander à leurs
conjointes
alors que les femmes demande parce que
toujours à leur conjoint
de pratiquer ce genre de choses conjoint
ou partenaire ou partenaires
occasionnels
alors on agit on aime bien entendu on va
pas dévoiler son identité
bien entendu mais tu es marié tu je suis
célibataire
oui et ton entourage est au courant
enfin je veux dire des amis c'est
strictement confidentielles personne ne
sait faire c'est réjean tu vois tous les
jours pour ton bureau personne ne le
sait mise à part ma maîtresse est ce que
cette occasion des problèmes de santé
est ce que par exemple des fois tu as d
pad et des cicatrices qui sont enquis
qui est occasionnel de santé directement
ou est ce que ça te ça donne des
maladies psychosomatiques
ou est-ce que quelles sont les
répercussions pour moi
masochisme me permet de retrouver mon
équilibre
par exemple sans savoir la nocivité du
tabac pour les marques je remarque que
je peux garder pendant un mois ou plus
je veux garder des coups à 20 ou 30 mar
pendant un mois
bon ils sont visibles a dit m ils sont
importants les gens en tournée elle pas
des gens quand ils voient des fois je
sais pas sur la plage et une grande
cicatrice tellement parce que c'est
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas un mot mais
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez une
fonction thérapeutique dans la société
absolument le dos les avis un mot que
j'aime beaucoup qui n'est qu'une la
science chez une dominatrice vaut tous
les dix ans du centre est
j'ai toujours pensé que c'est un type de
type il est rapide oui j'ai beaucoup les
efficaces que les autres parce que chez
une dominatrice tous les tabous tombent
et ans par le désir propre du sujet et à
ce moment là la dominatrice quand elle
essaie d'analyser ce qui s'est passé
chez la personne qui vient ce livre et
elle elle peut aller beaucoup plus vite
et beaucoup plus rapidement qu'un ticket
la liste qu'un psychiatre ou quand on a
une idée en france le prêt du nombre de
gens qui pratiquent ce genre de
j'ai quatorze mille couples jeudi couple
parce qu'il est très rare qu'il n'y ait
pas associations et les conjoints 14 mai
le groupe qui font partie de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le marché maintenant si
on pense ça aux hommes en général tout
d'un homme sur deux a eu une expérience
de soumission les rares qui la prolonge
c'est très très difficile de s'admettre
d'après mai
presque tous les hommes et c'est ce
genre de choses il ya dans les autres
pays comment ça se passe bien de 500
euros or les pays anglo saxons la
profession est reconnu que ce soit en
allemagne et aux etats unis
on est plaque avec fnac et chez les
chefs rebelles dans cette ville chère en
université mon ami van ryn la cour
guillaume sur le sadomasochisme et sur
sa pratique
il serait presque souhaitable de
dépénaliser cette activité et je précise
bien sans l'interdire
la prostitution traditionnel mais
admettre que c'est une psychothérapie
d'un genre nouveau
et quitte à lui donner des règles quitte
à créer un ordre qui t'a donné une
autorité morale me permettent de
garantir la qualité du traitement mais
c'est pratiqué dans le monde entier
c'est parce que oui dans le monde entier
dans toute l'histoire de l'histoire
le modèle le modèle du type de
domination que je pratique c'est à dire
celui d'une femme chez random s'est
abstenu aristote a épousé une jeune
femme la fin de ses jours et se faisait
faire gérer par elle tous les soirs un
nom et il est représenté dans tous les
chapiteaux romans des petites églises
romanes à genoux à quatre pattes
une femme nue superbe magnifique en
général sur le dos en train de flash est
donc c'est pas par du monde modérée de
ce qui est certain pour appeler à des
cadences du monde moderne etc
c'est quelque chose que tu as passé mon
permis oui il ya le plus célèbre des
bases de chizé l'histoire de france et
saint louis et masochiste masochisme ou
sexuelles flageller tous les soirs par
un jeune capucins et
je crois qu'il était parfaitement
conscient de ce qu'il faisait ou puisque
c'était sa culpabilité qui disparaissait
effectivement qu'on va faire parce que
comme je suis monarchie sunnite classe
les corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus